hello everyone and welcome to game 66
from the TCC Superfinal it's a stockfish
versus leo just zero and a lot of you
have been asking me in the comments how
come I never show again played the worst
stock fish wins well stock fish has a
different approach to games than Leela
hs0 as Lily is a neural network and
usually the games don't don't seem all
that hot I'll put it important to me and
not all that interesting yet it's an
intense approach the games and that's
why I rarely cover it but every now and
then there will emerge a game that will
be simply out of this world when I saw
this one it reminded me of a
Rubenstein's immortal game against rock
lab in 1907 which if you enjoyed this
game we were welcome to check that game
and also covered it on my channel but
okay without further ado let's check it
out as you all know the openings are
pre-arranged as so this time they play
what is well there's been a lot of fuss
about the Queen's Indian defense because
alpha zero really really outplayed
stockfish in pretty much every game
where stockfish tried using the the
Queen's Indian defense but okay here
alia has the black pieces so we'll see
what happens here we have d4 Knight to
f6 c4 e6 and Knight to f3 and now b6 the
Queen's Indian sorry b6 the Queen's
Indian defense is on the board and I
have to mention that when Lila played
this game or was this position where the
white pieces doctors was able to hold it
to a draw within the black pieces but
okay g3 the pinky toe variation Bishop
to e6 and now b3 with d5 Bishop to g2
the captures on c4 now comes Knight to
e5 and Bishop to b4 check King goes to
f1 this is a well known line it's plain
it's been played plenty of times between
human players as well the trip back to
d6 as the bishop and no longer has any
purpose now that the King moved and
Knight captures the pawn back on c4 now
we have Knight to d5 and now Bishop to
b2 we have nice to see six and here this
is move 10 and when Lila was playing
with the white pieces Lulu
for efore here but stockfish goes for a
different line efore has been played
amongst human players as well the move
little actuals but stockfish goes for h4
and this actually stop first that brings
a completely new game now for us to
enjoy here lila goes f5 most likely as
lee love lady for when li hua played
with the white pieces she wants to
prevent doctors from from pushing e4
Knight B to d2
we have castles by stockpile ela and now
King the g1 you don't want this King to
be on this diagonal when you finally do
push a efore the knight is nicely placed
here to support the dis advancement of
the pawn on e4
now comes b5 nice capture some d6 seek
after Sun b6 now improving the the
central pawn structure here and now
finally e 4f captures oops sorry about
that F capture sunny for Knight captures
on e4 and now Queen to d7 connecting
roofs developing the Queen and now nice
to g5 and already there's gonna be a lot
of action happening now the 90s and g5
as you can see black's pawn structure in
front of the king has already been
somewhat compromised there DF bone is
missing and Leela makes a further
weakening of the king side by playing h6
and stock fish no longer reacts to this
we have Queen to g4 and this Queen to g4
is not a piece sacrifice if even if the
knight was captured you don't have to
play H character sin g5 immediately we
could go Bishop Tadros on d5 you cannot
recapture because the Queen is unguarded
on d7 and after Bishop d7 you just go
back and then white pretty much has an
attack for free you're just gonna open
up the H file and win the game
so after this Queen to g4 move we have
grouped f5 by Leela blocking of this and
also the rook is now controlling in the
night here defending the knight on d5
but still the night it doesn't move we
have rook to e1 by stockfish now what's
the idea now well now if H captain g5
now do you see what stockfish hasn't had
in mind
Queen captures on f5 this is just
awesome
pawn captures Queen and now sorry not
the King Bishop cap
on d5 width check King 27 now you
capture on g5 with a discovered check
King goes to g6 and now rook to e6 check
wins the Queen I really have to give up
the Queen or if you go King to g5 then
comes f4 and look the g6 will be
checkmate
so after this rook to e1 move allele
goes back with nice blue f6 and now
Queen goes to e 2 and again it's not
possible to capture tonight because now
you just capture and there are so many
threats here you don't have time to
recapture here you would have to give up
the night because of the threat Bishop
captures knight on c6 and the Queen
captures on e6 so here you just have to
play something like d5 to defend the
night and then after you capture here
like I said it's not it's not even a
piece sacrifice and the white would just
be so much better here the queen is
coming into the attack and it will all
be over very soon
so after Queen to e2 we have rook to e8
now I'll bring this rook to help out
with the defense of the e6 pawn and now
finally the night goes back here you
could capture on e6 stockfish for some
reason does not go for this line tonight
captures it seems like a perfectly nice
pawn grab but still stockfish thought
thought it to be a less removed and then
what what's doctors played after rook to
e8 at first we have Knight to e4 now
nice the d5 and now push up to h3 the
rook is under attack rook to f7 and now
Bishop to g4 with the idea of Bishop to
h5 winning material rook F the e7 and
now we have rope to h2 Queen to d8 and
now we have f3 so strengthening in the
position here we have Knights to be 8 e
5 was also a possibility here but first
Leo decides to remain over the night we
have Queen to c2 now the queen is very
nicely placed here the Queen is eyeing
the h7 square and the nice the g5 will
once again become a very huge threat
we have Bishop to see it now Leela
really controls d6 square here but
stockfish now dies right into the attack
9 to the g5 and now
you still cannot care I mean the thread
is going to h7 this would lead to
checkmate but if you captured an H
captors again
now the rope will support to the Queens
the Queen's jumped to the h7 square
so after this Knight to g5 you still
cannot capture the knight first Knight
to f6 it's important that the knife
controls the h7 square but now comes
Bishop to h5 and this is just amazing
how this Bishop keeps wiggling in in
blacks position of course you still
cannot capture to do to the same
detonating idea Queen each it will be
checkmate so after Bishop h5 the rook is
under attack rook to f8 displayed and
now even bush up to g6 now taking full
control of the h7 square and preparing
to bring the bishop all the way back so
we have night the a6 now if you play
something like rook to c7 attack the
Queen to maybe get some activity doesn't
really help you Queen d3 still
everything is in White's favor doesn't
really help you rookie 7 you'll just get
this rock over here increase the
pressure and the white will just
continue building up so after Bishop g6
we have Knights to a6 by Leela and now
comes Queen to d2 with b4 now comes g4
and here comes nice to see 7 Leela now
decides to give up the b4 pawn to gain
some activity and stockfish decides okay
now it's time to grab some pawns clean
capture some before but now Knight F to
d5 attacking the Queen we have Bishop to
h7 first came to h8 and only now Queen
back to d2 it's okay for the price of
one point Oliva does manage to activate
the pieces a bit Knight to f4 we have
Bishop back to be 1 so this is just
fascinating here in this game ok
Rubenstein had had the black pieces
against throat levy but it's similar the
bishops were slicing all the way here
but now stockfish as the bishops are
slicing all the way here this is just
beautiful how this Bishop came all the
way from g2 to h3 to g4 to h5 to g6 to
h7 and then went all the way back to be
1 but ok Bishop to e6
now the knight and the rook are doing a
nice job covering these exponents so the
bishop can be activated we have night
2h7 now attacking the rook rook F to f7
and now comes g5 and here you don't
really have the option of closing the
position with h5 because g6 will win you
the rook the knight is controlling f8 +
f6 and the double shop of course is
guarding f5 so black would lose material
here so after g5 we have night - h5 and
now stockfish simply captures here we
have G captures and now comes d5 with
check seems like a weird idea why would
you deliver this check just to allow
black to close the position would be
five but stockfish has a very nice plan
Queen captures on h6 and it seems like a
weird move why would you allow rook
captures on h7 but this is what stock is
shared in mind Lila that's play rook
captures on h7 and now comes Luke
captures on e5 and this is just this is
just wild now after this move everything
everything is just working in White's
favor everything is all the pieces are
in are in the right place both the
bishops the rook the Queen end or even
the rook on h1 sorry about that will be
a part of the attack so what's the point
here okay if you capture the rook then
it's a game over Bishop captures on e5
with check and now you will either
capture here and you get the Queen
captures on h7 checkmate or you will
have to block for example not capturing
but you could go look the Geo King to g8
but then you get Bishop captures on h7
rook captures on 87 and now Luke G to
check Knight to g7 and now it's just all
over rope capture sin g7 King to f8 now
Queen captures on h7 there's no defense
again it's going to HEA to checkmate
whatever you play still you get
checkmate it very quickly so this is
what happens if you decide to capture
the rope but what about capturing the
Queen surely you can capture the Queen
if you capture the Queen it's a forced
line that leads stockfish into a into a
winning endgame
if route caps are screened then you get
rook captures on h5 delivering a
discover to check here after rook the g7
check now
you block with roof to g2 and now while
blocking check you also attack the
pinned piece so rook captures on h5
bishop
capture some g7 with check King to g8
you don't have the option of going to h7
you have to go in front of the rook and
now Bishop to f6 check wins the Queen
King f8 Bishop captures the knight is
under attack
so first rook captures here threatening
rook to d1 check the window bishop but
now just Bishop to e4 you attack the
rook rook to d1 check King to h2 and not
knight c6 and after the bishop joins the
game now you have this end game where
White has a bishop pair against the
bishop in the night both alia and
stalkerish have rooks but stockfish is
up to two passed pawns which will be
winning in the end a little of course
knows this so after rook captures on e5
a powerful move Lila goes for rook to g7
check so not capturing the rook or the
Queen but first delivering rook to g7
check and now we have looked to g2 rook
the g5 seems like a nice idea to
immediately attack the paint piece from
here but here rook captures is just the
winning for black as the night from h5
also controls the g7 square now so
instead after rook to g7 check we have
looked the g2 and now rook captures on
h5 sorry rook captures on h6 finally
grabbing the Queen you don't have enough
time to capture on g2 with check because
after Keane captures capturing the Queen
results in mate in one because both of
the bishops are controlling both the g7
and h7 so I have to rip the g2 we have
rook captures on h6 and now finally rook
captures on h5 nights - eh defending the
rook and now Bishop captures on g7
Knight captures rook captures on h6 King
to g8 and now once again you will just
attack the pinned piece so rook 2h7
so the stockfish will also win illegal
as night on g7 we have Queen to b6 check
King to h1 and now finally King to f8
and rook captures here so now we have
this position where both Leah and
stalkerish have a bishop but stock which
has two loops against the Queen which is
almost always favorable and not only
that stock fish is up three pawns
two of those are passports so that's
quite an advantage Quinta III oliva
preferred
position than the one we've shown where
it's immediately the endgame marilla's
down just two points but here it's still
a queen and the king is somewhat open on
each one so perhaps the game can be
saved via some sort of a perpetual check
we have Bishop to e4 now controlling
both f3 and d5 pawns
a very nice defensive structure in the
center queen te one check we have looked
the g1 now blocking Queen to III and now
rook to h5 we have king to e7 now rook
who goes back to g7 which check kinga 6
we have rook to g6 check King to f7 and
now look to h7 check so slowly but
surely you know Leela is running out of
squares for her King King to f8 now
comes Luke to f6 check King to g8 and
now and now comes no not this work but
look to east 6 and the thread is rook to
e8 checkmate you cannot of course allow
this we have Queen to e1 check balilla
King to h2 and now comes into f2 check
King h3 and now not allowing this
checkmate
so you thin the rock the finally the
king is on h3 so you can pin the rook we
have looked the c7 forcing allele at the
capture here on e6
but first Queen to f1 check King g4 and
now Bishop captures on e6 with check we
have Don captures on e6 now creating a
very strong pass pawn queen to g1 check
with King to h5 and now Queen to g3
still Leela tries to get something out
of the position is if stockfish were to
push the pawn immediately then 25 would
allow the game to perhaps be saved after
King g4 the King cannot block the pawn
and you know it's a it's still a game
but after this Queen to G to remove
stock which goes for up to f7 now
preparing to block this check with
Bishop to a5 which happens 25 check
Bishop to a5 and now Queen to d5
preparing to meet the push of the pawn
with capturing the rook but also just
you know making a move and pinning the
bishop here but King the g5 now we have
Queen to d2 check with f4 and now comes
Queen to f2 and here there are no more
good good defensive ideas for Leela here
you have
a forced checkmate so feel free to pause
the video and try to find it this idea
it's not it's not all that difficult
especially now that you know that it
exists for those of you who were able to
do it after pausing the video
congratulations you are an excellent
checkmater of neural networks and for
those of you who just one enjoyed show
Bush of 2h7 check after this move
Leela chest zero resigned the game and
stockfish created this brilliant
brilliant game that well as I said it
really just reminded me of that
Rubenstein's immortal due to the bishops
pair and the wonderful Queen sacrifice
now the only square available to the
king is came to h8 and now you get of
course you want to get to h6 and deliver
rook to FA checkmate but first you have
to do something about Queen captures on
h4 so here you create a shield for
yourself you put it upon 2 H 5 and now
after a little check King h6 and now
there are no more checks the rock is
controlling the f4 pawn and whatever
move black makes it will just be rook to
f8 checkmate
ok first Blackpool of course block but
either way so after Bishop to h7 check
allele hsz will resign the game and
really really just this moment here
after this Queen captures on h6 rook
captures and now this monstrosity rook
captures on e5 this is just just
beautiful yeah really an amazing game if
you haven't seen my video it's a really
really an old video Rubenstein's
immortal against wrote live in 1907 last
like four minutes it will be the first
link in the description below if you
haven't seen it and that you and you
enjoyed this game do check it out it'll
really blow your mind that key ballroom
is not really really an amazing player
also yeah now that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I think Lua is still in
the lead in the TCC by one point I think
this is game seventy seventy something
now already we've just seen game 66 but
few other games were played and you know
we're getting closer and closer to that
100 the decided the winner of the TCC
super final and you know who knows maybe
the winner will get the challenge alpha
0 or or not we'll see but yeah I would
- thank Benjamin Forbes Brown calling me
love kinesia which David Kiser and Roth
also Soler's for attribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos you're thankful
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content
continuing the Capablanca saga and you
know doing what we usually do here thank
you
and have an excellent rest of your day
and check out the the Rubenstein's
immortal see you soon